je suis né je vais être sincère quand on
touche à mon mec je peux devenir
ouf je suis la muscu que pour le
physique et humain qu'il l'a fait
récemment
ouais puisqu'il s'est permis de mettre
votre visage dans une raie et c'était
pas la vôtre non c'était pas là mais
malheureusement ce n'était pas la mienne
c'était la sienne c'est joey starr à
wiki sur instagram en plus annoncé sais
pas si on voit les amis ça qu'il a mis
alors alors on va pas alors moi je veux
dire un truc est juste car c'est vrai
qu'il arrête pas ouais ils allaient nous
cherche la non mais je vous dis joey
starr j'arrête pas de l'appeler au
téléphone et à chaque fois que l'appel
je sais que c'est sûr numéro il me dit
non ce n'est pas joey starr vous vous
trompé de numéro
moi j'arrête pas de lui envoyer des sms
il me dit non ça n'est pas joey starr je
sais johri que c'est ton numéro de jouer
arrête de mettre des choses sur les
réseaux sociaux
viens on va se voir tous les deux ça va
très bien se passer en plus je vais te
dire que tu es déjà lâche peut rien
faire de plus
des regards dans l'état dans lequel tu
peux pas faire plus zéro donc t'inquiète
pas on va se voir gentil moi je sais que
tu as du mal à bouger tout ça mais veut
on se voit et quand je t'appelle arrête
de dire que c'est pas ton numéro je sais
que c'est toi
alors arrête donc on va régler ça avec
toi ce week-end
et puis j'espère que tu accepteras de me
voir je vous fais bien sûr mais ils
n'arrêtent pas sur les maillots sociaux
et il fait le go sur les réseaux sociaux
ce que je dis et quand je t'appelle
titus titus savez vous de toi il paraît
que la cpt trépidations pas tout à fait
mais c'est sa petite réputation je vous
jure de frapper va dire les hôtesses de
l'air et les îles avoir fait un animal à
un singe de cours dans ces cas-là un mec
qui l'appelle ou qui vient enfin c'est
plus personne oui mais moi ça fait sa
fille j'arrête pas de l'appeler donc
répond frérot et puis on va se parler
tous les deux il n'y a pas de problème
et puis tu verras au pire des cas ça
sera peut-être une bonne occasion pour
toi de te refaire les joints bac versée